the man accused of kidnapping 13
year-old Jamie Clausen killing her
parents is scheduled for his first court
appearance today 21 year-old Jake
Patterson faces two charges of
intentional homicide and one charge of
kidnapping his lawyers would not say if
he has confessed to the crimes this
video shows a messy home cluttered with
games and books
Jamie was found on Thursday by a woman
walking her dog about an hour north of
Barron Wisconsin her home town she had
been missing for 88 days Gail is in
Barren this morning where she spoke to
members of Jamie's family who are taking
care of her and boy Gail I bet they're
hugging her ever so tightly this morning
Fionna hugs that they don't want to let
go I'm standing in front of the jail
right now where for the past four days
and past four nights Jake Patterson has
set behind those double doors in a cell
all by himself
I saw a sheriff's deputy here last night
who told me that he saw him he has not
spoken to him but I said what does he
look like what is how is he feeling he
goes all I can tell you is he looks like
his mug shot expressionless with no
emotion
well contrast that to the cost family a
lot of emotion there from the people who
love Jamie Claus they say she has been
laughing yes laughing and talking a lot
they say but they don't know much about
what happened to her while she was held
captive for 88 days so we spoke with two
of Jamie's onsets aunt sue Allard and
lynn claus and her cousin Lindsey Smith
who calls Jamie her new little sister
Jamie's family told us why they're going
to court to see Jake Patterson later
today and how they have handled the
grief of losing Jamie's parents I look
at all three of you sitting here today
because as exciting and exhilarating as
this is there's also another very
painful part that your brother-in-law
your sister your aunt is no longer with
us how do you handle those two thoughts
at the same time we have back-burnered
their death kind of how I've yeah it's
like they were they were murdered and it
was shocking and horrible and hideous
and but we didn't know where we had this
little girl that we couldn't find we
kind of said okay as horrible as that is
we got a
here and we got to find her and we're
gonna get her and I think that's partly
why we didn't quit looking for her
because for them - it was like yeah
we'll find her
you know there's a lot of it's doing a
lot of questions the big question is
where did he pick her Oh from Target it
was it from a picture did he see her
somewhere in public yeah how did you
choose her and why yes was she your
obsession where did this come from and
the the other thing that's so troubling
is that he had no connection to the
family and I'm sure you Oliver act your
brains about it did anybody know this
guy yeah yeah there's no mr. Patterson
will be making his first appearance in
court do all plan to go there
a way there yeah why do you want to be
there justice for Denise and Jim justice
and for Jacy
Oh make sure I won't be at every
everyone what will you think when you
see him for the first time I'm sure
anger disgust I want him to know that he
messed with us as a unit and that good
winds and that is not him and Lindsey
you work in the prison where he is I
work in the jail yes where he's being
held yes have you seen him I have not
and I have talked to the sheriff my jail
captain and they're doing what they can
and I will not deal with him Mike came
it mm-hmm
what does touch you most about the out
pouring because I would imagine people
all around the country reaching out to
you I cannot I cannot believe all the
things people want to do like the
message that I got wondering if we had
some of Denise and James as close that
they could get because they want to make
Jamie a quilt hairdressers that we know
that have offered bring Jamie in
whenever you need to you know will clear
out the salon will do her hair will do
her after-hours
or I mean people are just giving and
giving and giving it's just incredible
you know the family members told us the
first thing they wanted to do to prepare
for Jaime's homecoming is get her room
ready they got our new bed a headboard
with shelves they said because they knew
she would like that her favorite color
is blue so there's lots of blue in the
room and the most important thing
butterflies Jaime class loves
butterflies they said butterflies
symbolize to them rebirth